When my genetic test it comes back, will I receive results via email? Yes. Is there a clarified coaching call that goes with it? No, but you can schedule one. So you can schedule, you can schedule to talk to me anytime you want. There's just a feed of that. So that's why we do these Zoom calls so you don't have to do that.
And that's and you also have access to the read your genes course. So with the genetic.
When the genetics come back, you're going to get the full report which is like 250 pages and drinking like drinking from a fire hose.
Most people are going to look at that.
So I actually put together a genetic summary report. So you'll also get this genetic summary with just the genes highlighted that you really, I think are a concern. So most people just look at that.
And then you also get it so that genetic the full genetic reports about 250 pages to genetic summary reports about 17 18 pages.
And I also give you a genetic action step report which is like three pages. So just some dietary things to change and then some some supplement things that I want to change.
I just didn't want today for somebody that I didn't make any supplement changes. So but usually there might be one or two things that we might add or change on your supplements based on your genetics.
Because I've been on so many supplements, you requested that I let you know as I run out so you can advise me on whether to quit or to continue one. How would you like to share that.
Send it to info at counters clinic.com or you can send it to labs at counters clinic.